nora tyton examines the relationship
between john wilkes booth and his older
brother edwin booth
born to british actor junius brutus
booth the siblings aspired to become
actors as well
edwin succeeded and was one of the stars
of his day while john struggled in the
craft
ms tytone explores the rivalry between
the booth brothers and the possible role
it played in john wilkes booth's
assassination of president abraham
lincoln at fort's theater on april 14
1865.
nora tyton presents her book at the
abraham lincoln presidential museum in
springfield illinois
the program is one hour
good evening
the scene
in ford's theater
on april 14
1865 is stamped in national memory
there was the gunshot
the actor
jumping from balcony to stage slashing a
knife before the footlights
lincoln fatally hit slumped in a chair
rage at the union victory
and hatred for lincoln
drove john wilkes booth to pull the
trigger
this story has been told many times
but there is more to the story of john
wilkes booth and the assassination of
lincoln than the familiar facts we all
know
it is a story largely unexplored
a story hidden
in private letters diaries memoirs and
manuscripts
and it is the story of a remarkable
and dysfunctional theatrical family the
booths
but above all
it is the story of john wilkes
and the man who was his rival and
competitor
his older brother edwin
edwin booth's name is forgotten now
buried by his brother's infamous deed
but a century ago
he was the actor king
the greatest most influential star on
the american stage
four years older than john wilkes edwin
was a dramatic genius
a prodigy who earned colossal national
fame before the civil war began
during the war edwin booth owned his own
theater on broadway
where he could earn
in a week the civil war equivalent of
two hundred thousand dollars
and he gave generously
of those profits
to the union war effort
he called himself corporal edwin booth
he called his actors the federal
dramatic core
and together
they raised thousands through charity
performances of shakespeare
for the widows and orphans of u.s
soldiers and for military hospitals
but the crowning moment
in the wartime career of this patriotic
actor
was when he was summoned to washington
to give command performances for his
beloved president lincoln
on a special occasion
the third anniversary of lincoln's
inaugural
for six nights in 1864 at the national
theater by special arrangement
with lincoln and the first lady
edwin booth played hamlet macbeth and
other shakespeare plays
to deafening ovations
this was john wilkes booth's older
brother
so how could it have happened
one brother the 19th century's most
notorious assassin
and the other
a loyal supporter of the union
and that century's brightest star
the answer lies in part
in their relationship they were
competitors in the profession of acting
and they were political opponents
their rivalry would shape both their
lives
but it would prove particularly
disastrous for john wilkes
the record of this brothers conflict is
not hard to find
it is in playbills dramatic reviews and
especially in the booth family's private
papers many of them here at the lincoln
presidential library
booth's assassination of the president
while certainly the act of a confederate
sympathizer and a conspirator
can also be understood as the tragic
finale of a tangled family story
i started researching the brothers
at a place called the players this is a
private club
founded by edwin booth himself in 1888
in new york with his very close friends
mark twain
and u.s president grover cleveland
the club still stands today it still has
membership and it holds
the most rare
portions of the booth family papers
the room where edwin lived in this club
until the last days of his life is
carefully preserved
and when you walk in nothing's been
changed
on the wall near his desk
is a sign he hung there it's a warning
it's a motto taken from the tomb of
shakespeare at stratford on avon and i'm
going to read it to you
good friend
for jesus sake
for bear to dig the dust enclose it here
blessed be the man
that spares these stones
and cursed be he
that moves my bones
when i read that coming in to do
research it hit me
because i was there to move those bones
that was a warning
and the book i wrote my thoughts be
bloody is a result of my
excavating
and tonight i'm going to tell you some
episodes from this family's remarkable
story
but before i do
i'd like to say that the booths were the
premier theatrical dynasty of the 19th
century
edwin and his father junius were
considered towering geniuses and they
stood
at the center of our nation's cultural
life for 60 years
from the 1820s through the 1880s
so from the early decades of our
republic to the end of the gilded age
the booths
lived in the spotlight
of the national public eye they were
tragic they were scandalous they were
eccentric they were dysfunctional and
haphazardly endowed with genius
they were strivers they wanted wealth
and they wanted to be figures of
national prominence
and as public figures they witnessed or
participated in
defining moments in the century
from the settlement of the west to the
california gold rush
from john brown's execution
to the 1860 presidential election
and of course
to the years of the civil war
so in many ways the booth story
is our national story in the 19th
century
the story begins
with this man
junius brutus booth
father to edwin and john wilkes he
arrived on american shores in 1821
on a ship
ironically enough called two brothers
junius was a shakespearean actor he was
an international star
his bizarre
volcanic and sensational interpretations
of shakespeare sparked riots in london
he belonged to a circle of famous men
romantic artists that included lord
byron and the poets shelley and keats
junius was a radical non-conformist he
rejected christianity
he dabbled in islam and hinduism
he was a vegetarian which in the 1820s
was like being a lunatic
he was an opponent of slavery
and he was a genius who could write
poetry sculpt marble
speak ten ancient and modern languages
and act
booth had what he liked to call with a
gesture up here at his forehead
mind
he believed he was a rare being
someone separated from the rest of
humanity by his incredible talents
and american audiences agreed
booth was huge here he toured nationally
every year he was admired by presidents
from john quincy adams to andrew jackson
and he raised his two sons edwin and
john wilkes
to believe that fame was a marvelous
prize
mind or genius he told these boys
happily belongs to no age
crime sex or condition
instances he said can be quoted when
even from the most despised classes
genius develops itself and towers above
all the circle of the human race
powerful words to tell adolescent boys
and despised classes
were the key words
for junius
had an important reason to leave england
and come to america
the threat of scandal
he had come here
not with his wife who he left in london
but with his pregnant mistress and over
the next two decades the couple had 10
children all of them illegitimate
including edwin and john wilkes and it
was when the boys were in their early
teenage years
that junius's wife
came to baltimore from london
to hunt her husband's second family down
she pursued edwin john wilkes and their
mother
through the streets of baltimore
shouting insults
harlot scarlet woman at the boy's mother
and saying even worse things to the
children
she wanted to establish in a very public
way
the illegitimacy
of the american booth children
because she was bringing a suit for
divorce before the courts of baltimore
this noisy public
scandal
humiliated the booth family
and the hefty divorce suit bankrupted
them
in court
junius brutus booth was forced to
testify before a judge that his sons
edwin and john wilkes quote were the
fruits of an adulterous liaison
a father so famous
and so infamous
afflicted his sons
leaving them both with driving ambition
as they grew older but also a burden of
shame
and that early legacy
was a challenge for edwin and john
that edwin later acknowledged toward the
end of his life when he wrote
i am glad i have not sons for when a
name becomes great
it had better die
with the one who made it distinguished
now here in this picture
our juniors and his son edwin booth
the photograph was taken very soon
after junius chose edwin to be his
theatrical apprentice
and the heir
to his fame that he had created here in
america
tellingly there are no photographs of
john wilkes booth with his father
growing up
in an actor's house
a place filled with if you can imagine
it
hundreds of costumes staged swords
makeup cases
all the paraphernalia of acting
had left edwin and john both with a
yearning
to be a part of the theater
but only one
would have that chance early on
and as junius noted
my sons are as wide apart as points on a
compass
they were very different boys
john wilkes was physically strong he was
the image of his father he was
charismatic aggressive
bold
but he was not a scholar
he had a difficult time reading he had a
slow memory
and no head for languages
edwin
though
scrawny and admittedly strange looking
physically weak
he would cry when bullies in baltimore
gave him a hard time
and his brother had to fight his battles
for him
nonetheless edwin had an intuitive grasp
of shakespeare's words even from a young
age they even said at the age of four
he was a child who inherited not his
father's looks but his father's
intellect and so for junius edwin was
the obvious choice to be his successor
on the american stage and it was that
choice that sowed the
first seeds of conflict between edwin
and john wilkes
for junius took edwin out of school at
age 12
making him his assistant and together
this pair
traveled every year from albany to new
orleans savannah to cincinnati
while the father acted
the son was a valet but he was also a
guardian
junius was an incurable
alcoholic if he drank too much or found
his way to a tavern he could refuse to
perform that night or if he did go on
stage he would break down
mid-performance weeping and screaming
or he'd give all of his income for the
evening away to strangers
it was edwin's job to keep this man
out of taverns on time for his
performances and disciplined it was not
work for a
child john wilkes envied this job he
thought
he said it was a golden holiday for his
brother to do this
he never understood what that reality
was like for edwin
edwin's childhood was miserable he
missed a chance at a formal education
but as training to be an actor
the experience was ideal
his father performed all the great roles
and edwin absorbed and internalized
everything he watched from behind the
scenes
meanwhile
john was at home in maryland with their
mother
watching her endure more public
humiliation for of course junius's by
now ex-wife stayed in baltimore and
continued to persecute the family
because of the damage to the booth's
reputation by this adultery scandal
john wilkes's mother was determined
that john of all her children would be
socially respectable
she wanted to train him to be a
gentleman
and so all the cash that edwin sent home
from touring with their father she spent
on boarding schools etiquette classes
even dancing lessons for john wilkes
but john wanted a different future
denied his father's teaching denied the
experience of touring he studied
shakespeare alone by himself at the
family farm and it was not easy for him
to do so
in 1852 the great junious brutus booth
dies after 30 years dazzling american
audiences
he dies on the road
a trip to san francisco to act for the
minor 49ers and to tour the california
gold fields
turned dangerous he caught a fever on
the steamboat coming back and died
the loss of the father freed john to
step off this course that had been
prepared for him to be a gentleman
and to try to become an actor
but in that race
he was far behind his older brother
this woman is laura keane
you may recognize her face and name
she was the director and the star
of our american cousin the play
performed when lincoln was shot
and she was the woman
who held the dying president's head in
her lap
what is less well known is that laura
keane was edwin booth's mistress
and she played a key role in launching
his career
the pair met in san francisco after the
death of junius brutus booth
laura was 10 years older than edwin
already an established actress but early
on she recognized his talent
she wanted to be his co-star his
director
and it was her that planned
their first tour together
he was the leading man she the leaning
lady
edwin's genius was evident to everyone
who saw him act
his performances in new york and boston
attracted the interests of very powerful
people
drama critics and writers
one of these was the abolitionist julia
ward howe
future author of battle hymn of the
republic
she adopted edwin as her protege in 1858
publishing poems in his honor in
national magazines
these writings helped cement his
reputation
and being the friend of julia ward howe
also shaped edwin's political views
so it was with the help of these very
advantageous friendships that by age 25
before the civil war began
critics were calling edwin booth the
greatest actor of his generation
john wilkes
started acting
at age 19
in 1857
but without training
without experience and without
connections he could only get work as a
soup
that's short for supernumerary the 19th
century term for an extra the walk-on
guy with no lines
you might think john could have traded
on his famous family name
but edwin who by now was the head of the
family in virtue of his stardom and his
income
wouldn't let john call himself a booth
not until this younger brother had
proved some ability on stage
edwin said
could he use that last name so until
john proved himself he had to be
j.b wilkes on playbills
so jb wilkes toiled as a soup in
richmond virginia for years it was low
paid work and humiliating
john earned typically 300
in a nine month season
edwin by contrast could earn that much
in a night
it was finally in 1860 that edwin
allowed john to start touring as a star
on his own
using the name booth this was after
three years as an extra
but john was not free to go where he
wanted
edwin divided the map of the country
right along the mason-dixon line in 1860
not for political reasons but for
business reasons
edwin wanted to preserve
his monopoly his profits
in theaters in new york boston and
philadelphia
john was free to tour in the south edwin
said where cities were small
farther apart and profits were less but
the north where the big money and the
crowds were was going to be edwin's
so john's first experience of touring as
a star
was in montgomery alabama in the fall of
1860 this was the turbulent presidential
election that split the union
it was a disastrous experience for john
wilkes
the people of montgomery instead of
coming to see his plays were too busy
debating secession and forming militia
companies and drilling in the streets to
ever walk into a theater and worse
john's manager
a drunk
accidentally shot him in the rear at
this juncture and put an end to his
attempts at performing for the season
but in
1861 when the civil war began
john had recovered from that injury
his sympathies for the south were strong
his childhood spent in maryland and the
years he spent working in richmond
shaped his political feelings and he was
not afraid of a fight
but he did not enlist in the confederacy
even though he was inclined to do it
he had a golden opportunity
when war broke out
edwin left the country he had been
invited to perform in europe in london
in paris
so for the first time with edwin gone
there were no restrictions on john
wilkes booth as to where he could act
the map was wide open and civil war
audiences without edwin booth they were
hungry for another son of the great
junious brutus booth
they were eager to see john wilkes
this picture was taken at that moment
and it captures i think unlike all other
pictures i've seen of john wilkes booth
the sense of possibility even optimism
as if this were maybe one of the best
times in john's life
he was making money he was getting
bookings even on broadway where he'd
never been allowed to perform by his
older brother and he was living and
profiting in the north this moment did
not last long
reviews of john's work
as hamlet as yago as [ __ ] were
scathing
john was like a stuntman he was great in
the bruising battles that you needed to
do on stage but the moment a soliloquy
was required he was lost
and when edwin returned from europe in
late 1862 once again john would be left
scrambling for work
this is a scene from the draft riots
that took place in new york in july of
1863
this event would be the closest
that the booth brothers edwin and john
wilkes ever came to scenes of actual
combat during the civil war
in that summer
a union officer a man named adam bedeau
he was staying at edwin booth's mansion
in new york he'd been injured on a
battlefield in louisiana and he came to
the actor's house to recuperate
john wilkes was there too
he had no home of his own
and he stayed with his brother whenever
whenever he wasn't working
and he had to follow one rule while he
was staying with edwin
never talk confederate under the roof of
edwin's house
in july
as these three men john wilkes booth
edwin booth and
captain adam bedeau
were staying together riots broke out
across the city to protest the new
federal draft
african americans and union officers
were targets of violence
john
at this point was forced to help hide
the injured captain badou and
his african-american medic
in the basement of edwin's house
protecting them from lynch mobs
arsonists and gangs
eventually the riots died down an order
was restored and adam badou left the
city safely to join the staff of general
ulysses s grant
for whom he would work for the rest of
the war and would be standing at grant's
side at appomattox when lee surrendered
batto late in life
marveled that he had spent the period of
the draft riots being protected from a
mob by john wilkes booth
he wrote that he was amazed
that in all the exciting period of the
riot the future assassin of president
lincoln said no word that indicated
sympathy with the south
but in private
john had been furious at the role edwin
forced him to play during the riots
to his sister john confessed
imagine me
helping that wounded soldier with my
rebel sinews
in 1864
when edwin was performing for lincoln at
the national theater
john wilkes
was snowbound on the high plains of
kansas where he had gone to act in town
hall theaters he was trapped by
blizzards he earned very little money
and frustrated after seven years of
hardship on stage
john decided to try something new
oil it had been discovered in western
pennsylvania at the beginning of the war
in a place people like to call petrolia
or oil dorado
following in the footsteps of thousands
of other wartime prospectors john sank
all his savings into building three
wells these derrick-like structures that
you see here in almost like a forest in
the picture
the scheme he hoped would make him a
rich man and perhaps free him from the
drudgery of touring on the western
theatrical circuit
it was a bad gamble
notice how many derricks are in this
picture and try to imagine how many of
those were active wells
not many
john was not one of the lucky
prospectors
he had chosen
a financial game with as much hope of
success as acting unfortunately
edwin booth meanwhile hit a geyser of
cash
as the owner director and star of that
broadway theater the winter garden
his box office
made him a millionaire
or the civil war equivalent of a
millionaire
from the stage of the winter garden
edwin could launch attention-grabbing
stunts as he did when he performed
hamlet
100 nights in a row without stopping
becoming the first actor ever even from
shakespeare's time to do such a thing
and he received a gold medal from the
people of new york for doing that
john wilkes had not been invited
to be a partner in the venture of the
winter garden theater
not even as a stage manager or a ticket
taker
as usual edwin booth had shut his
brother out of the family business
so in his shack in petrolia
very similar to the one pictured here
john papered the walls visitors reported
with images of his famous family
when he returned to new york for visits
john wilkes did not tell edwin and the
other booths that his oil venture had
been a bust
on the contrary
he told the booths he was becoming rich
and that he would never act again
because petroleum he said
was more profitable than the theatrical
profession
at that time
john was recruited by the confederate
secret service
so when the news
reached edwin booth
that his brother had shot the president
the actor was not at all surprised
he said the intelligence hit him on the
forehead like a hammer
he wrote
my mind accepted the fact at once
i thought to myself that my brother was
capable of just such an action
his brother's murder of lincoln was
devastating to edwin
but the reactions he records in his
letters seem to speak less of the blow
to the union then of the blow to the
actor himself
oh where has my glory gone
edwin wrote in agony
i have been blasted in my hopes by a
villain edwin vowed to quit acting
forever in penance for his brother's
crime
in a letter to the american people that
he wrote in the summer of 1865 and
published in various newspapers edwin
said i shall struggle on in my
retirement
bearing an oppressed memory and a
wounded name
to my all-too-welcome grave
but edwin booth did not keep this
promise
six months
after lincoln's body was laid in the
tomb here in springfield
edwin announced his return
to the stage more surprisingly still
he brought a production of our american
cousin
to the stage of the winter garden
theater in september of 1865
and who was starring in it his
brother-in-law john sleeper clark
fresh from the old capital prison where
he had been held under suspicion of
assassinating the president
laura keane forever associated with this
play
was disgusted
this play she wrote ought to have only a
memory of shame
and horror for you
and your family
but few people shared laura's disdain
the public welcomed edwin booth's return
when he walked on the stage of his
broadway theater in january 1866
less than a year after the assassination
worshipful crowds packed the auditorium
weeping and applauding at every line he
spoke
a new york theatrical agent from the
civil war period
explained
edwin booth he said was devoured by a
thirst for fame
a very wise ambition for fame brings
money
and edwin booth drew the largest
prophets
after his brother's assassination of
lincoln
americans hungered
to see edwin on stage not only for the
thrill that his genius
could deliver
but to feel the sense of connection he
provided to the martyred lincoln
edwin booth was a touchstone almost
to that tragic last scene of the civil
war
when the actor
finally retired
after a long and very profitable career
he took up residence in this luxurious
club i mentioned before the players
in gramercy park in new york
this club he decorated
with images of his father junius brutus
booth and filled it with a collection of
his father's costumes stage swords and
paraphernalia
the club was also filled with treasures
treasures donated by its
wealthy and distinguished membership
first folio editions of shakespeare
sculptures paintings
edwin's club was a gathering place for
high achievers for geniuses for men of
rare talent and ambition
and included people as i mentioned
earlier like mark twain grover cleveland
the inventor nikola tesla
at the club
surrounded by these bright intellects
and great talents
edwin booth was never
troubled by allusions to the
assassination
everyone at the players
pretended edwin had never had a brother
and they never spoke lincoln's name in
the actor's presence
but if you visit there today and you see
this room he lived in unchanged
you'll see by his bed at eye level
still hanging there today
something the actor looked at every
morning and every night
a photograph of john wilkes booth
over the years edwin has been largely
forgotten
his talent
the trajectory of his career erased
out of respect for edwin during his life
newspapers in new york
rarely wrote about the assassination of
john wilkes
only after edwin died in 1893 did a
popular fascination
with john wilkes and the assassination
begin to flourish
a legend was created
about the dramatic genius of lincoln's
killer
about how he had been the inheritor of
his father's greatness
and in generations of myth-making about
john wilkes booth
edwin's name and his story
have been lost
leaving his younger brother to stand
alone
on the stage of national memory
as he no doubt would have wished
thank you
[Applause]
sure
and i hope you have lots of questions
because i'd love to answer them
his judgment
what a great question
was john wilkes booth a true patriot of
the south or did his rivalry with his
brother
cloud his judgment or mine
i think he was
a zealous confederate
i have no doubt about it i mean every
everything he ever wrote
is filled with that conviction
but i think what happened for him
that there was a parallel
metaphorical
between
the imbalance between
the power difference between his brother
and himself that seemed to mirror
the fates of the north and south during
the war
they were both unequal contests
and certainly john wilkes there's no
question in my mind was a
true confederate
but i think this relationship with his
brother
drove him
to a place where he was trying to
compete
in a fight that he could never win
what of the story
that
junius once threatened andrew jackson's
life
of the story that junius brutus booth
once threatened the life of president
andrew jackson
i've read the letter
people said that junius brutus booth
they wondered if he were insane
or simply drunk all the time
and
and if he and their
opinions differ on this point
but it's certainly clear that he loved
his brandy and a lot of his letters when
you read them are scrolled they're
they're confused
um they're almost
impressionistic
and
he would often say to theater managers
he'd send a head you know i may not make
it there i'm drinking today don't
announce me till the beast arrives
meaning himself and so
the letter he wrote to andrew jackson um
talking about a hanging i think um
to me reads like a drunken joke
you know i don't think it was an actual
threat of assassination i think he was
just blustering in a way that a guy
who'd had two pints of brandy would
bless her but he was
friends with andrew jackson i mean their
friendship would i think permit that
kind of teasing or you know what we
would see as completely inappropriate
statements to make to a president um but
it was
i think it was that kind of friendship
forged on the american frontier
you know in those heydays of of the
1830s um and late 1820s
junius in fact in addition to being a
great drinking buddy of andrew jackson
also drank a lot with sam houston the
texas um
you know the first president of the
texas republic they were very close
friends and there was this kind of
masculine camaraderie that um all
circulated around the tavern
that they shared so i think his
his threat was a joke clouded by alcohol
there are two questions here that are
similar so i'm going to
kind of combine them
one ask if you can elaborate about john
wilkes booth's connection with the
confederate secret service
and the other one
asks how do we know
that john wilkes was connected since
those records were burned
i'll answer
that in two short parts
what i found
in my research i mean it's very
difficult to
document the doings of a secret
organization
but
when john
went to new orleans to act
at the saint charles theater
in the spring of 1864.
he met
individuals there
who were blockade runners for the south
and who
were under suspicion by federal
authorities because new orleans was
occupied by federal authorities at the
time as being connected with the
government in richmond
and so
theater
managers and actors noticed those
relationships and noticed that john
wilkes corresponded with those men after
he left new orleans
it is hard
to write about the confederate secret
service in great detail but we do know
that john deposited money in a bank in
washington dc after attending a meeting
in canada that has been characterized as
a secret service meeting so
looking at the flow of money looking at
who he met and where
people i think have safely
posited that he was involved in a secret
service
there are also several questions that
are similar in asking how
edwin could have such control over john
wilkes and where he could perform and
the question about not using the booth
name yes
the people i've left out tonight and
talking with you are very important
characters and they partially answer
that question which is very important
question
marianne holmes
is the woman
the poor this poor woman the mistress
the pregnant mistress remember who came
with junius from london to the united
states the mother of the ten booth
children
her livelihood
depended
on edwin booth
not only her livelihood but the rest of
her children her daughters her younger
sons the sons that were younger than
john wilkes
and so when edwin
and the father go to california
on this
mission to the gold fields where they
hope that they'll act for the minor
49ers and become very wealthy and junius
dies on that trip
edwin stays in california for five years
that leaves marianne holmes the mother
and all the children including john on
the maryland farm with no money
for five years they had no
income they had no wage earner to
support them
and the hardships they experienced if
you read the journals of this family
from the time they were close to going
hungry at certain periods
so when edwin returns
a star
in the late 1850s a wage earner the
person who's going to revive the booth
family fortunes
that gives him tremendous power in this
family
because
whatever john wilkes did
as he asserted his career
if it affected edwin's wage earning
that affected the fortunes of the whole
family because edwin was supporting the
mother his sisters
his other brothers
so that
by making ed by edwin becoming the head
of the family he was basically taking
juniors brutus booth's place and that
gave him almost a paternal authority
over john wilkes and so having a booth
out there acting who wasn't a great
talent who might tarnish the name or who
might lead to
audience fatigue
was an issue that the whole family was
concerned in and that gave
kind of impetus to edwin's power over
john
there are a number of
people who want to know what happened to
the other booth children
oh it is it is a sad story um
there was another brother
junius jr whom they called june
who like john wilkes didn't have that
spark that edwin had you know he was a
they said he was mediocre in everything
which was very cruel um
but
he tried to make a living as an actor
too and
what you see
in his later life is it's heartbreaking
edwin as we know was the equivalent of a
millionaire right he was a towering star
especially after the assassination
but even junius in his very small niche
that he'd carved for himself as a
leading man
had to ask edwin
if he could perform at theaters on the
east coast
even as they were into their 40s 50s and
60s i mean it was sad
and
so junius had a very small career he was
always struggling for money and he'd
write letters to his brother saying i
have a man's typical problems too many
children and not enough income
and he never really made a success of
anything and he was completely in the
shadow
of edwin
and again like john wilkes junius was
never
you know his fortune was not made by his
older brother edwin could have helped
him and he didn't
did
do you believe
if
booth broke his leg after
shooting lincoln and jumping onto the
stage
you know i think i can answer that
question very specifically
i'm
i've read a letter
an amazing letter
written by
the neighbor of the booths at their
family farm in harford county maryland
there was a woman named mrs elijah
rogers who lived next door to the booth
family for years
and when
wilkes's body
was released from where it had been its
unmarked grave in washington dc
and returned to the booth family
for bree burial in the booth family plot
in baltimore
this neighbor
was present when the casket was opened
because of course edwin had bought a new
coffin for his brother
and she saw the body
lifted out and placed in the other box
and she describes it's so hard to read
it's so graphic because of course she
had known john wilkes when he was a
toddler when he was growing up and she
you know doted on him like any neighbor
dotes on any little child who lives next
door and she said
you know his body was broken the leg was
snapped and the bone protruding through
the skin
and when i read that i thought oh you
know this had been a decade you know
well not a decade but many years had
passed from the ceiling of the casket to
the opening of it
and so she saw a bone broken and
protruding through the skin um i don't
know what you want to do with that piece
of evidence but that's what i read in
the letter written by the woman who saw
his casket opened
what was edwin and john's personal
relationship
we know they had a professional rivalry
and their politics was different but
did they get along otherwise
there were
physical fights
in edwin's house in new york during the
war over politics you know the kind of
fights where
at the breakfast table someone tries to
to choke the other person or punch them
and
ended in
john being ejected down the front steps
of the house
so there were you know there were very
ugly moments and
that kind of physical antagonism is
something that you see in the brothers
even when they're children i mean that i
found these
newspaper clippings
reminiscences by
kids who'd grown up in baltimore with
the booth brothers you know and so when
they were older they gave their
reminiscences to newspapers so i
remember when edwin and john wilkes were
little boys and they were putting on
theatrical performances for the children
of the neighborhood in basements of
hotels in baltimore
and even then edwin and john wilkes had
this
resentment for each other where you'd
have
these classic situations where edwin
would steal a costume from his father's
wardrobe and take it down to one of
these basements where all the
neighborhood kids had paid a penny to
come in and see you know some crazy play
that the boys had written
and he's wearing his father's stolen
costumes and john wilkes
tells on edwin the father comes in a
towering rage breaks into the basement
drags edwin out by the scrap of the neck
and beats him because of course it's the
19th century and
that i mean
that kind of you know brotherly um
i don't know just cruelty to each other
was was typical of their relationship
do you believe that there was a
conspiracy beyond john wilkes booth that
edwin stanton was involved and andrew
johnson was involved
um i
i
don't
know i don't believe that
i think he acted you know on his own
is it true that john wilkes was kept in
a draconian prison
continuous
prison conditions after his capture
i
from
what i understand he
was shot
uh
on site
before
there was any
imprisonment yeah he was never
imprisoned
um
adam bideaux was a
theater critic yes
um can you describe some more of the
relationship between badou and edwin
booth absolutely this is one of the best
parts of researching this book the fact
that general grant's private secretary
who was with grant through some of the
hardest
parts of the civil war
on the battlefields
at the headquarters
was constantly corresponding
with edwin booth that entire time
you can read their letters at the
players
this private club edwin is established
they're beautiful they had
this incredibly close friendship and
adam badeau before he became a soldier
was a drama critic in new york and he
was the one
alongside julia ward howe they were all
friends who really launched edwin's
career so in many ways edwin's great
success was the creation of adebado this
theater critic who endorsed his
interpretations of shakespeare and who
called him the great shining talent of
their generation
and their
remarkable friendship that lasted
unfortunately
not beyond the civil war
this closeness that they shared and
their incredible letters
adam badeau was the one who after john
wilkes killed
lincoln
brought these letters
to general grant to other people in the
lincoln administration and said look
edwin booth is a union man i have 300
letters here from him where he's saying
bring me the head of robert e lee on a
plate or you know go
kill those rebels you know very
patriotic letters and so adam bado was
an advocate for edwin in that roundup of
suspects after the assassination
but when
but it
the breakdown of their relationship
reveals kind of the
the cruelty and the ruthlessness at the
heart of this star
because once edwin put that play our
american cousin up on stage in boston
i think adam badou
he couldn't
accept that
and he couldn't accept edwin's
coldness towards him after all of the
labor adam badeau had gone through to
prove edwin's innocence
so their friendship ended
in 65 but adam badeau would go on to be
general grant's um ghostwriter helping
him write his memoirs and he also is the
best source we have about edwin booth he
wrote a lot after edward after edwin
died about their friendship and about
the character of this great actor
final question
what is your next book focusing on
do you have any ideas
actually this is this is going to sound
completely crazy and i'm sure anyone
uh
listening uh
in my family is going to say why are you
saying this but i am fascinated one of
my favorite parts of writing this book i
mean this family story i don't think i
will be ever ever able to find sources
that are like
this family sources again i mean the the
the drama the the intrigue the mystery
the passions the divisions in their
letters were just
exhilarating to read and
extremely sad as well
so finding another family to write about
that matches the booths i think would be
very hard
so what i'd like to do is one of my
favorite parts of researching that
didn't involve the family was
documenting that trip to california that
junius and edwin took in 1851
it was an amazing trip you know they
went from new york
down the atlantic coast by steamship and
then hiked across the isthmus of panama
through the jungle
and then up again the pacific coast on
steamship it was an amazing journey
and thinking about that part of the west
california the southwest
it just it gripped me and especially
gripping was to realize that general
grant not general grant then he was
lieutenant grant
followed the booth's route two weeks
behind them he was two weeks behind
junius and edwin
crossed at the same part of the isthmus
hiked through the same jungle trails he
lost
a hundred men to cholera on that trip
two weeks later
and i always wondered what would have
happened if edwin booth had died of
cholera on that trip
you know as so many of grant's men did
two weeks later
would we be
you know talking about what happened in
ford's theater today
ladies and gentlemen let's thank nora
titan
[Applause]
nora tyton is a historical researcher
with a focus on 19th century america
for more information visit nora
tytone.com
julian zelizer history professor at
princeton university recounts the
presidency of jimmy carter mr